wake you up middle of the night
come for you and your children I feel a
great swirl of pity for the poor soul
that comes to my school looking for
trouble some believe that the first
mutant was born thousands of years ago
he was some kind of God and he's gonna
rise again you are all my children and
you lost because you follow blind
leaders
no more false gods I'm here now
he always had four followers like the
Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse together
we will cleanse the earth to the
strongest and take everything from them
you means to destroy this world
billions of people killed oh say can I
start
the world needs the x-men splay you're
gonna join them aren't ya
I wanted me to get out of the house more
right it's all of us against a god let's
go to war
forget everything you think you know
you're not students anymore
your x-men
everything very sweet very full
they saw the end of the world I could
feel all this death Jeanne it was just a
dream
the forest you
I've been called many things are many
lifetime
Krishna Yahweh ever since the world
found out about mutants there have been
secret societies who see them as some
kind of second coming or sign of God
they believe that tens of thousands of
years ago ancient being was born the
world's first mutant you are all my
children and they lost
because you follow blind leaders but I
am here now I'm here for you wherever
this being was he always had 4 followers
he would imbue with power like the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse got that one
from the Bible or the Bible got it from
him what is it
Oh God he can control all of us
the world needs the x-men that's why I'm
here to fight not all of us can control
our powers
then don't this is war
everything they feel
will fall and from the ashes of their
world
we'll build a better one
I've never felt like this before
you